hey everybody this is Phil here with
Tony and we're here to talk about
disintegration now we've seen
disintegration a couple times a
multi-player there was a closed beta not
long ago but Tony you've gotten a sense
of what it's like to play alone so
what's it like well it's definitely very
different from what we've seen a
multiplayer for those that don't know
the premise of disintegration is it is
part f PS part RTS so you have your
units moving around on the ground that
you can command but then you're also
piloting this grab cycle and from there
you're using your own abilities and
you're shooting at enemies but in
single-player you're doing more specific
missions right so you have objectives
and it's not just about wiping out the
enemy every time right there's some
exploration to it there's more to learn
about the world as you're going through
these different biomes and so it
definitely feels more maybe educational
is the right word because you're
learning so much more about this world
which I do find very fascinating I've
definitely been interested in what's
going on with disintegrations campaign
there's a lot of interesting lore stuff
it seems like but we've only seen just a
little bit of the surface of that so can
you tell us a little bit about like what
the conflicts is about what these why
everybody's a robot that sort of thing
not everybody as a robot that was kind
of one of the interesting hooks here it
is like set in the future it's like
right around apocalyptic kind of times
and humanity is basically trying to
survive by putting their brains into
robots and so anybody who does that
those are the integrated but then you
also have the people who are still human
and they're called Naturals the set up
is basically a civil war between those
who have integrated and become robots
and those who still want to stay human
and kind of keep that a free-will net
humanity right just not be a part of the
system black shuck leads the rayon which
is like the main robot faction that
you're fighting but then you play as
this guy called Romer and he leads his
kind of band of outlaws and they're the
ones kind of going around rallying up
humanity to fight against this robot
uprising but you're a robot too right so
Romer is yes Romer himself is a robot so
like the rayon faction is kind of fully
given over to like automation and being
machines and that sort of thing like
their humanity is gone but roamers still
retains some of that and in fact
like part of their goal is to hopefully
one day disintegrate and actually just
be human again to like get rid of the
robot part gotcha and there we are with
the title yeah there you go
so how does that work in actual missions
like who are you fighting against you
know it when we played in the beta we
saw a lot of battles against other grab
cycle teams and it's like a campaign
it's got to be a little different
there's got to be different enemies and
stuff so what are the rayon kind of like
there are different kind of enemies that
you fight for sure and in fact you
actually have this sort of ping ability
where you can highlight enemies in the
environment learn more about them it's
um it's less of a radar and more about
learning about the world as my
understanding because you can also ping
like architecture in different items in
the environment to learn more about the
world but those enemies that you scan
obviously you also fight and there are
different types you know when it comes
to RTS is you can use your imagination
as to the different units right you have
your your heavier guys you have your
quick or smaller units and it's the same
for you and your team the striker class
is like a big mech and he gets a mortar
you have the Ranger which uses more of a
sniper rifle
the sniper also has this thing called a
slow field it slows down your enemies
and their bullets within the field so
you can kind of use that to like flank
people or set up combos you have these
warriors which are kind of like the most
human-like unit and they have a stun
grenade you can think of them maybe kind
of like halo Spartans whereas the
striker is more like a javelin suit from
anthem or something so you have
different types of your units which are
fighting you know an equal amount of
varying enemy types in the beta we were
mostly just fighting other teams and
other grab cycles but are you able to
customize your grab cycle as you're
playing through the campaign are you
able to bring different weapons to the
fight well each mission is its own kind
of self-contained thing and each one
gives you a specific grab cycle to use
so you don't get to customize it in a
single player you do in multiplayer
right like you can make your own loadout
you can pick the perks you like but in
single-player you do have a specific one
for each mission that said you can sort
of generally
upgrade yourself using these things
called chips not to make the halo
comparison but you know the director of
this game did also you know work heavily
in the halo series in a minor way maybe
comparable to like the skulls from halo
where you could like find one in
equipment and it would change sort of
how you play each mission you can
experience disintegrations campaign for
yourself when it launches it'll be on PC
Xbox one and ps4 it's still planned for
later in 2020 and keep an eye on
gamespot for more desintegration
coverage in the future
[Music]